.
INISH
L  CONGRESSWOMANGRE   LGRTH
WA.ST.WHAT ARE TTIONS YOU
TTI
BA
ANYTHING IMPORTANTE FIRSE OFATR
Y  TRED, WHY DIDT  A
THEY'RE TALKINOTHER
NG THE MATERIALS
FROM JANUARY 5th ANDthER
DELETED, AND THE SECRET SERVICE
ING WAS DELETED THAT
U
BED.E THOSE TWO STEM
MAYBE THEY DON'T.
THO FI IS TO
DRL
>> DO YOU THINK THE COMMITTE
SKH TIME O
THISTTG DRAGGED DOWN
>>.BIT HOLONS ANKI
YOU I THINEP IS TO
THE MATERIALS TO SEE TO GEANIO
TO THAT QUESTION.NOW THE AR  WA?
I THINK THEY SHOULD BRINE VICE .
TO PRESIDENT  FORFRONT OF THAT
H R PERSPECTIV,
PARTICULARLY VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE.
VICE
WHHAT LOADINOUD DID NY OF HIS AA
DOCK.ANTHERE WAS AL ONE UMP WHE
BOD TO
SAYINGE
IS.
BASIS TO RESIST THE SUBPOENA AN.
THUB
>> DO YOU THINK -- AGAINTHIS
ISHEF S.
OND
IS GOING
WOULD ANNOORE THE
MIDTERMS, AND WH IMPACT DO YOU
THINK THAT IS GOING TO HAVE?ISG
I THINK HE THIS CAN'T
HIMSEL IS
UNDERMINING THE INVESTIGATION ZY
SAYING,  I
LOOK AT THIS.
THEY WANT TO STOME
IN
ANI'G SO ON AND SO FOR
HE'S GOING TO WAGE CAMPAIGN
THATTO BS BEEN PERSE S AND BYNE
REPUBLICAN FIELD
>> ABSEL
SOLY UNDERSTANDST HE
CAN TENNANHE
NK VING Y TOE PROBABLY  D'T --
PROBABLY GOING TO WIN, AND TY
DON'T WANT TO WAST ELSE.
AND THE ONLY WAY HTS
R MINATI
SOMEONE IS ABLE TO RUN  CAMPAIGI
PROBABLYTHINK DeSA
RUHIM?
>> I THINK IT'S QUE POSSIBIN ON
IF IT'S A NDIDAT THE
THE VOTE WILL SPLIT, ANDS
GOTOHE DOE HAV 50% OR
HEH % WITH  TAKE ALRULES, WHICHI
BASICALLY WHAT HAPPENED IN 2017.
>>K OT TO